saying go to christian who has a guest
in studio thank you yasser we are indeed
with a victor of today's round david
brosky david welcome to the show and
what a game to come back uh to our show
a game a victory against a wanderer
liang an incredible victory with the
white pieces did he surprise you with
the car com and his approach um the car
wasn't a surprise like i mostly prepared
for e5
but uh
he likes to play this g5 in the car
sometimes
uh but he actually
a6 was a big surprise for me like i'm
trying to understand how you can come
why i want to combine a6 and g5 like i
can see the point
but
i'm not sure it's worth the tempo
and you kept up with your plan bishop to
d2 knight to e1 a very typical plan in
this type of positions and then
target the newly created weaknesses on
the kingside f4 let's keep it up let's
keep it going i'm not sure where he made
his mistake i'm
yeah and fg5 was nice because if he
takes in b3 then gh6
gh6 he has to go back to h8 and i
thought i have a lot of compensation
maybe i can do something more direct
like bishop d3 or i can just yeah he
takes b3 i have three pawns his his king
is h7 is coming in lines yeah i know i
was wondering if they can even just go
bishop d3 here like
this is looking really good it's looking
really good they're just you know i've
seen enough at least from a practical
perspective yeah yeah i don't know what
the engines say
so of course he took back knight c1 f6
takes i was expecting bishop f6 hanging
onto the pawn
but like okay i understand that he wants
he wants to activate his his knight
but i'm not sure it was worth the pawn
because after after he took i wasn't too
sure where his compensation was i was
just a little confused so i think this
was the moment where he could have
potentially activated his pieces in time
he missed a bit with the move queen to
d7 bishop to g6 seems to have been the
better movement okay and then knight of
three that was my favorite three and
knight f5 okay bish before
yeah
and uh
probably just go queen to e7 perhaps
right now ah okay i guess e7 is a better
system it's a better square right
yeah
because but still he played the move
queen to d7 it made a lot of sense tried
to activate the roots right yeah
nevertheless you managed to finally find
enough time to get your pieces
into play right now how did you assess
it at this point uh at this point i
wasn't sure because my h5 bishop is a
little loose
but then at some point i think after
maybe knight g3 i realize i'm
more or less
winning here in my opinion at least yes
because i mean his attack is dead and
my knight in e5 is a monster and i have
an extra pawn
absolutely and uh let's keep on with the
moves i think another
fun moment came uh towards the
conversion phase when you played this
move g4 knight g3 queen to f2 rook to g7
i you had this uh brilliant move queen
to f6 which was spotted with the idea of
knight f7 knight h6 oh knight f7 knight
h6
oh oh oh yeah that's just
that just finishes the game the queen is
lost
it was just geometrically very pleasing
okay yeah i mean what i did is
completely winning too because the
status and just to interrupt you for a
second we do have a massive result in
this one rochelle who did win her game
against her good friend jennifer
you let's go back to the game
and uh you did take on g3 this is
winning as well yeah very easily winning
as well
david congratulations a big victory
against the rating uh favorite of the
event how do you feel right now after
six rounds thank you i know i'm very
happy with this game you know i was
minus two going into this round that was
that was pretty bad you know after
getting hit by a train in round one i
haven't really found hadn't really found
my form but
you know i'm really happy because this
is my biggest scalp in quite a while you
know about rating being at 2600 is
always nice but especially you know in
these circumstances like i understood
that i had a target on my back and he
wanted to take some risks but you know
that's part of chess still three rounds
to go maintain the momentum yeah right
now and we'll see you in tomorrow yes
thank you our congratulations david